all right this next topic i've really
been hesitating to do it because it's
completely speculative but sometimes it
becomes so hard to explain behavior in
empirical ways with facts that we have
that it becomes difficult to avoid
speculating so i'm going to say this
super clearly this is speculative
thinking out loud based on the number of
people who have written to me you guys
and said
could vladimir putin be terminally ill
and could that explain his behavior
which is unhinged and seemingly reckless
as well as potentially self-destructive
to himself and to russia vladimir putin
seems to be making uh decisions that
apparently can't end well for him nor
for russia uh the economic damage being
inflicted on russia as a result of the
the sanctions in response to putin's
aggression
according to some could damage russia
economically for decades
and what many of you are thinking from
the emails i'm getting is could some
horrible illness explain it one person
wrote to me and said putin's face is
pudgy could he be on steroids for some
medical condition could that be one
reason for his rambling and his
increased aggression it's very vague
it's very speculative
another post on the subreddit uh the
david pakman show subreddit said is
putin terminally ill and that's why
consequences
don't matter to him
speculative
another aspect to this is the pictures
of putin sitting cartoonishly far away
from people during recent meetings
yesterday i retweeted an image from the
morning of putin meeting with his
supposedly top advisors and he quite
literally appears to be at a 50 foot
long table 50 feet away
from his closest advisors
and there's many possible explanations
for that he's generally known to be a
germaphobe it could be that simple we
heard well as he's just very careful
about kovid
it could be as we talked about on
yesterday's bonus show putin may fear
that someone within his advisors might
try to kill him and so he's keeping
physical business i mean it really could
be anything
the other aspect of this that people
have talked about is that in two videos
from last week videos which in principle
were filmed days apart vladimir putin is
wearing the exact same suit and tie he
seems disheveled he seemed sort of
confused leading to speculation that the
videos were filmed at the same time and
putin's not really well enough to be out
and filming videos regularly again it is
completely speculative and what's going
on here is we're all trying to come up
with explanations
for unexplainable behavior from vladimir
putin is he simply this much of an
unhinged authoritarian and he's not sick
and he's just doing this anyway does he
have a death wish is he such a
narcissist that he thinks he won't end
up hurt no matter what he does or you
know at the tail end of that is is he
terminally ill and just trying to go out
with a bang no one hypothesis is that
much crazier that much more crazy or
that much more likely uh one journalist
udo lishkes who's the former director of
the german broadcaster ards studios in
moscow
also brought up the possibility that
putin could be suffering from a serious
health issue said um
after seeing these recent videos of
putin he just doesn't look at all like
he looked months ago and lishkey's
highlighted claims
by foreign affairs specialist in
academic fiona hill who said putin could
potentially be ill so
that's the whole story you all now know
everything i know and everything that's
been said
uh i'm curious to hear your thoughts
understanding that i'm this is not a
news report of putin being sick this is
could this be going on many of you seem
to think it is and you've brought it to
me
and
now you basically know all of the claims
that i'm aware of let me know find me on
twitter at deepakman i'm curious to hear
your thoughts
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below